we're here at the streets of Willow
Springs racetrack Acura brought us out
this is a sponsored video by the way I'm
just super excited they have the super
super car
well that's something I didn't
anticipate which is we're not even at
the right track right the right location
this is the right place this is also the
biggest salmon eco brand integration
we've ever had and we went to the wrong
commercial set and we're there's some
cameras that's probably where we need to
go nope but there's multiple tracks here
and so we actually have to drive a mile
within this location to get to the other
racetrack where the Acura shoot is
taking place they're gonna want to film
later at night so they can show off some
LED lights 1:18 and we have to wait till
sunset to even have the show started
Brad near Edwards Air Force Base which
is where most Smith went in Independence
Day I have a shot list
I'm gonna go see it and maybe even drive
all right it's an expensive car but
because of that it's really cool and I'm
on board with this because it means I
get to go check out all the cool
features of this cars got like several
different electric motors and all that
dude
this is a carbon indestructible roof
[Music]
okay yeah sounds good they're not gonna
let me drive it but I really really want
to drive it
oh look at that this track is so long
man
here at Golden Hour
Oh
no it's my buddy Jason from engineering
explain hello hey man he has the YouTube
channel engineering explained and
basically talks all about how cars work
you know we have a very fancy car here
there's a 3.5 liter twin-turbo v6 in the
back powering the rear axle sandwiched
between that engine and the transmission
is a direct drive motor so you've got an
additional electric motor and then
you've got two electric motors up front
one for each wheel so there's two motors
working at the exact same time yep so
there's a v6 engine in the back and then
behind that v6 engine there's another
direct drive motor and then so that
electric motors actually linked up to
the crankshaft of this engine and then
it's all sending all of that torque from
the engine and the motor to the rear
transmission and then splitting it to
the two rear wheels so this has a
limited slip differential in the back so
if one wheel is flipping it will send
more torque to the other wheel okay I
don't know but I do know a thing or two
about electric motor see yeah there's
two electric motors attached to each of
the front wheels basically allows the
tires to rotate separately they're not
locked together one electric motor for
each front wheel correct you can have
one motor sending torque to one wheel
you can have both motors sending towards
both wheels you can even have a negative
torque applied to one wheel and a
positive torque applied to the other
wheel so this is a hybrid car this is a
hybrid it's not like the classic hybrid
where you're saving gas mileage what is
it at home you press your foot down you
get the immediate torque of the electric
motors while that turbo engine is
spooling up and then gives you full
power okay so that's how it's like in my
car where it's like I'll be sitting at a
stoplight and I'll slam the pedal down
and I'm like what happened okay now it's
starting to go because the motor has to
like rev up and that's it yeah that's
how it's like in your car yeah as you're
coming up to a corner the second you let
off the throttle it starts regenerating
so before you even on the brake so let's
say we're coming around this Bank right
here this tire right here it's going to
have a negative torque applied to it and
an outside tire can actually
rotate faster than the inside wheel to
help push the car out of the corner and
accelerate you out what do you mean by
negative torque as in it's regenerating
energies electricity is being taken from
the braking of the motors it's turning
the wheel into an electric generator and
capturing that energy which causes you
to slow down and it helps you rotate the
core because you have a larger negative
torque to that inside wheel so that's
creating a yaw moment to rotate that
vehicle
yah-yah-yah way and that's actually
super cool because in normal cars you
only get positive torque when you hit
the throttle traditionally with car
tires it'll go the direction the wheels
are pointed but if you're riding around
a racetrack really fast if you're coming
in too fast to that corner and it sees
that you're about to oversteer which
means the back of the car is going to
rotate around you and you're gonna spin
out it'll break those outside tires to
prevent that from happening now Lane now
if you come in and you turn the wheel
too much and it can't actually turn the
car it'll break the inside tires
that's called understeer so that it'll
actually help rotate the car for you
okay so that's more like like when
you're in a boat or like a kayak or
something and you just put the paddle in
the water and once a it drags you that
directly okay so it's literally just
you're writing down the racetrack and
it's like just like throwing it down on
the ground just to kind of drag you that
drag so it's not a boat it's a car that
sounds like magic there the floor plates
under your feet are made out of carbon
fiber it I've never in my life heard of
a car that's even remotely similar to
this can I Drive it I just want to drive
it really well don't think you first
spin I'll settle for that all right it's
okay I
got it okay get it okay I'm Katherine
Katherine I rent I'm doing pretty good
seeing less me wondering what's going
alright now a little bit do you drive
cars often I race
[Music]
oh man I'm not really used to riding in
supercars
I never has before yeah no going around
these churchy so you break going into
the turn and then you say you try and
break in a straight line as possible
because I'm really really good in this
steering is very direct is it real
and basically it's very responsive car
so Jason was telling me like electric
motors themselves they compensate for
like depending on the orientation of the
steering wheel right what do you want
can I can I Drive it
yeah yeah I can yeah all right okay
foot on break
[Music]
they just switched he gets to drive
after all that no you know what you
should check out engineering explained
on YouTube videos about how cars work
I'm kind I'd play by the rules and like
Ren here
me
- she let me drive the car oh how was
his driving
the car is incredible I've never even
been in any car nearly this fast are
both for the other episodes going on
your channel they're gonna be on
engineering explain it's a YouTube
channel about how cars work I don't have
a channel we got a supercar driver here
rigs burger yeah man I even my
terminology because I see I live in here
why did you guys miss me Jason thank you
but more importantly Catherine thank you
so much that would I will be thinking
about that right for once
thank you that was awesome it was great
getting to ride now can I just keep the
car you don't get to drive it anymore
at all that's
okay you take the keys they may not bite
us